we recreated every single challenge from
sweet game but made it extreme and
whoever wins wins 40 000 in cash the
first challenge is red light green light
but this time the doll might have a mini
gun
oh my god start the challenge
she just went crazy yeah that was a
multi-kill i'm so scared
oh my god what is that let's see who
gets hit by these balls they can't move
because there's currently red lights
oh my god i almost died
okay i'm gonna use the community as a
bullet shield
landon we needed you for views i died
oh my god i see the ending i'm right
here i'm right here at the end i'm
staring down the barrel of the gun okay
good night we did it i did it
oh my god there's only 30 seconds left
wait is it always flat yeah i could just
never switch it back green and he's lost
jimmy don't do this to me man hey you
don't need forty thousand dollars tell
me one reason why you need forty grand
cause there's so much i don't need it
i'm very rich okay at least you're
honest
i'm the only one that didn't make it huh
yeah we hate australians the next
challenge is honeycomb i split you all
randomly into four teams and the last
team to build their assigned shape gets
eliminated and the thing is the wool you
need to build with is on the other side
of the obstacle course guarded by giant
mech soldiers i feel like the huge
police robots weren't in the show cause
it's extreme begin the challenge
blasting to finish is eliminated let's
go chris you me chris blew a b bloopy
the guy right next to me just died
guys if you die you don't respawn be
ah careful don't go here chris
i didn't know there was a robot right
here
oh i died
get whoa get whoa get woke
red team literally has to make an
umbrella or screw all right now all the
teams are currently collecting wool and
they have to run back and build their
shape over there go go go go go okay i'm
going back
we got triangle oh thank god i don't
think that all right let's do this
umbrella whatever's so cool
what is he doing banned him he's just b
he's breaking everything
how do you how come you guys have
teammates i do not know how to make a
circle hey we're almost done we're
almost done i'm just gonna leave it up
to god on this one umbrella's missing a
few circles missing a few stars missing
a few triangles missing one come on we
just gotta work together
we did it yeah red team red team
oh we did it circle's done jar versus
triangle i think the star kids are
screwed man grass triangle's missing one
oh my god they won't move i believe in
you chris
oh my god and triangle oh my god chris i
love you and there they go on to the
next challenge we've now split all the
remaining contestants into two teams
team red come on red team blue let's go
server start the battle let's hit these
kids
okay i stayed up there for a long time
we're losing we're losing we're losing
come on man
i'm not going in right now i'm gonna
wait back wait challa is here kill
chandler i gotta infiltrate in the back
infiltrate in the back come on right
over pound
oh
no
no
carly you alive
yes i'm alive i knock somebody off i
knock somebody off win for me
and please we're going to give everyone
wood swords
oh god kill them kill them kill them
we're winning we're winning we're
winning we're winning
yeah
baby yeah
obviously the next challenge in squid
games was marvel's but we just got giant
marble cannons to shoot marbles at you
we're going till half of you dies server
started up
whoa
i don't know what to do i was running
i'm so scared
i'm so dead i have one heart hurry up
and die no
no
i died
all right we're getting close six more
five more
two more people
i'm on hop house please
stop the marbles
give me no more marbles
call it
important time in this round okay bye
the next challenge is obviously glass
bridge but like with marbles we brought
the cannons back
you have five minutes to get to the
other side go ahead and begin
someone jumped i'm scared the first jump
is the left okay
that was a
lie but dead serious this next one's
left again
no it's true it's true go for it you
went like twice you only have four
minutes in 12 seconds go to the left
jump left someone jumped
go go go we're running out of time three
and a half minutes go left all right
send it all right
[Music]
it can't possibly be four in a row
that's four to row on the right side it
can't possibly be five in a row
it wasn't five in a row
i say we sent george no i disagree with
that on my mama's life it's right guys
we have two minutes and 40 seconds okay
i'll jump
for the first time in forever hey you
only have a minute left carl and george
you guys are trillionaires go okay yeah
probably call can go i'm not going i'm
not going i'm not going if the challenge
just ends here i keep my money no no
there's 30 seconds and there's like six
jumps hey we lost unless you guys go
one freaking job
[Music]
oh
these three are about to slaughter each
other for 40 grand next challenge the
final challenge is a fight to the death
over a massive pool of lava the last
person alive walks away with 40 000
are you three ready to murder each other
yes
start the challenge
how about you stop negotiating and start
to get hit and gaining warranty let's go
and blitz
oh
have mercy
oh they're not teaming
the team is over
[Music]
what are you gonna spend the forty
thousand dollars on a bunch of cars i'm
gonna pay my bills thank you for
watching everyone subscribe